- [Voiceover] Let's see
if we can figure out
the volume of this figure over here.
They've given us some of the dimensions.
We see this side over
here is two centimeters,
this is seven centimeters,
this is 12 centimeters,
this is five centimeters,
this is three centimeters.
And so like always, pause this video
and see if you can figure it out.
Well there's a bunch of ways to do this,
but the way I'd like to do it is
just to break it up into
two rectangular prisms.
So what I'm gonna do is, in fact most
of the reasonable ways to do this
would be to break it up
into two rectangular prisms,
and the ones that jump out at me
is one prism like this that is
three centimeters wide,
five centimeters high,
and then it is seven centimeters long,
or seven centimeters deep.
So this one right over here.
And if this part right over here
was transparent you would
see it look just like this.
You would see it look just like this.
And so this one once again,
it is three centimeters wide,
seven centimeters long.
So this distance right over here
is going to be the same as
this distance right over here.
So seven centimeters long.
So the width times the length
times the height is five centimeters.
Gets us to, let's see.
Three times seven is 21,
times five is equal to,
20 times five is 100,
one times five is five.
So it's going to be 105.
We can say 105 cubic
centimeters, cause you have
centimeters times centimeters
times centimeters.
So this blue part right over here,
this blue rectangular prism,
has a volume of 105 cubic centimeters.
So now we can separately
figure out the volume
of what I'm now highlighting
in this magenta color.
What I'm highlighting
If this was transparent, you would see
this part back over here
and right over here.
So what are its dimensions?
Well, we know its height
is two centimeters,
we know that this
dimension right over here,
I guess you could say its depth,
we could call it that,
is seven centimeters.
But what is this right over here?
If we want to consider
this, maybe it's length,
or maybe it's width, depending on
what we want to call it.
Well, let's see, this whole
thing is 12 centimeters,
from here to here is 12 centimeters,
and we know that from here
to here is three centimeters,
so this piece right over here
must be nine centimeters.
So that must be nine centimeters,
is this distance right over here.
So the volume of this magenta part
is going to be nine centimeters
times seven centimers
times the height, times two centimeters.
Which is going to get us, let's see,
nine times seven is 63,
63 times two is equal to,
60 times two is 120,
three times two is six,
so it's 126 cubic centimeters.
So the total volume of the entire thing
is going to be the volume
of the magenta stuff,
which is 126 cubic centimeters,
plus the volume of the blue stuff,
plus 105 cubic centimeters.
And that's going to give
us, for the entire figure,
six plus five is 11,
so one plus two is three, that's really
one ten plus two tens is three tens.
And then 100 plus 100 is 200,
so we get 231 cubic centimeters
is the volume of the entire thing.
Fascinating.